why are they testing for weed before not
anymore not anymore just give like don't
give a [ __ ] about weed anymore how do
you do do you stop smoking pretty much
done at this point uh i find it a lot
easier to get my weight down because i
walk around around 157 um right now i'm
152 pounds and it and a lot of it's just
like cutting the weed out at night i get
the [ __ ] munchies like every single
time and i could be [ __ ] two days out
from weigh-ins and get high be like i
could just eat like they always [ __ ]
get you no matter what munchies will get
you that's that's so funny that you you
actually told what your walking weight
is now most people don't like to talk
about it yeah it's weird i don't really
i've never
yeah i've never really uh understood why
like i think i i know why it's because
if if people uh admit what they're
walking around at
then
they're uh
potentially
admitting that they're gonna be
compromised when it comes time to fight
that's a good that's good i mean like i
can make a that could make sense i i
usually i'm actually lighter right now
going into this
these last couple weeks than i ever been
just because my last like four or five
weight cuts
there's been times where i'm like i
might [ __ ] die like you're lagging in
that [ __ ] bath friday morning trying
to get the last two pounds off and it's
like
scary it's like [ __ ] and like everyone
i'm not just saying like bragging about
it like that's just what fighters deal
with you go you have to lose those last
two pounds friday morning and everyone's
different some people like what no i
don't i i don't do but you know i'm a
pretty big bantamweight but right now
i'm i'm like two pounds less than i
usually am so i'm pretty excited about
fight week and going into the weight cut
yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's
selling out everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]
yeah dude